bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte on
a beaucoup parlé du glyphosate en
agriculture mais cet herbicide n'est pas
seulement utilisée dans les champs les
forains sont aussi pulvérisé
c'est une pratique qui permet de se
débarrasser des feuillus des essences
qui sont moins intéressantes sur le plan
commercial mais elle n'est pas sans
conséquence notamment quand on est
confronté à des feux de forêt
à
voilà le glyphosate telle qu'on connaît
un herbicide utilisé pour éliminer les
mauvaises herbes en agriculture
[Musique]
mais voici un autre visage du glyphosate
au canada les sociétés forestières
utilise l'herbicide pourrait détruire
les espèces de plantes qui font de la
compétition aux conifères et boisé comme
le tremblay le boulot selon les chiffres
rendus publics en 2017 au canada 81
mille hectares de forêts ont été
aspergés c'est la superficie de 115
mille terrain de football et la pratique
a cours depuis des décennies nous sommes
en colombie britannique orange de la
famille sky doll près de prince george
dans le nord de la province
dans ces forêts le glyphosate est
utilisé en abondance la raison est
simple le tremble pousse partout
jane le fils de la famille est ébéniste
ce matin ils préparent des planches de
trembles son bois de prédilection c'est
le bois le plus coloré textures et qu'on
a dans la région j'irais même jusqu'à
dire que c'est le plus beau bois la
colombie-britannique mais peu de gens
qu'il dit parce qu'ils en ont jamais vu
ces images d'hélicoptères c'est james
qui les a tournées tout près d'ici
il documente l'utilisation du glyphosate
en milieu forestier dans la province
il milite depuis des années pour changer
les règles qui forcent l'élimination de
la presque totalité des feuillus dans
les coupes forestières le glyphosate des
tonnerres by side puis ça ils tuent les
feux du sans pour autant détruire les
conifères qui en tolère certaine dose
le produit est souvent l'option la moins
coûteuse pour éliminer les feux du ca
fait mal de voir qu'on fait disparaître
certaines espèces de nos forêts j'aime
les tremble moi j'ai grandi entouré par
des forêts tremble font partie de nos
forêts et maintenant forestière et
gouvernement qui disent on veut se
débarrasser de ces arbres ils font plus
partie de nos forêts ça me rend furieux
[Musique]
ans
ici tu y avait des trembles partout il
était perçu comme une menace pour les
pâques ils les ont arrosés avec du
glyphosate
ici tout était mort sauf les pins les
troubles n'étaient plus des branches
mortes
maintenant c'est une grande dans nos
cultures de pain
[Musique]
donc pour quelqu'un qui ne va pas en
forêt ça semble parfaitement normal et
verdoyant les arbres poussent rapidement
mais en même temps c'est une seule
espèce d'arbre le problème c'est que ces
arbres sont incroyablement flamme à une
étude albertaine qui a démontré que les
pains sont neuf fois plus à risque
d'être ravagée par un incendie
si on les compare aux trembles à l'été
2010 est la communauté de williams lake
au sud de près georges a dû être évacué
[Musique]
un demi million d'hectares de forêt sont
partis en fumée dans la région deux ans
plus tard la chercheuse louis-daniel
étudie le comportement de ce feu
historique
elle s'intéresse au rôle qu'ont joué les
feuillus comme ici près de l'aéroport
le feu se dirigeait dans cette direction
quand il a atteint une section avec
quelques feuilles où il a perdu de son
intensité
et quand il est arrivé à s'étrangle il a
été freiné les arbres ont tous survécu
pour la chercheuse
il ne fait aucun doute que les feuillus
permettent de réduire l'intensité d'un
incendie
les forêts de tremble de boulot et de
feuillus en général en raison d'un
changement subtil dans l'ombre âge
l'humidité et la température elle
résiste mieux au feu quand un incendie
se propage au sol et qu'il frappe ce
changement d'environnement
le feu va se déplacer ou brûlé beaucoup
moins intensément et cette résilience
qu'apportent les feuillus irait bien au
delà du feu une monoculture et plus à
risque d'être frappée par des insectes
et des maladies pour louis daniau
l'utilisation d'herbicides doit être
reconsidérée afin de favoriser une plus
grande diversité en forêt je crois que
ce sont des concepts dépassés
il y à de nombreuses recherches qui ont
démontré depuis 10 à 15 ans tous les
avantages de promouvoir une plus grande
biodiversité en forêt notamment pour les
arbres reboiser on utilise du glyphosate
pour tuer des trembles et de la
végétation compétitive
eh bien le mot compétitif est cruciale
ces plantes compétitionne des conifères
qu'on souhaite voir grandir afin d'avoir
une industrie forestière forte
ça veut dire qu'on met seulement une
valeur la valeur financière
devant toutes les autres valeurs
[Musique]
jing nous emmène sur une coupe
forestière traités au glyphosate est
bien une
les rares plantes qui ont survécu sont
souvent déformée presque plus rien ne
pousse ici les conifères non plus de
compétition on a détruit la biodiversité
et la nourriture pour plusieurs animaux
on entend des oiseaux mais je n'en vois
pas ne rien arranger pour eux ici pas
d'insectes sauf des moustiques rien pour
nourrir les abeilles c'est pas ça de la
foresterie
[Musique]
dans cette forêt de recherche on épand
du glyphosate mais pas assez pour tuer
les plans mis qu elles survivent souvent
déformés les chercheurs tentent de
comprendre comment se comportent les
rhhby cdh à long terme lorsque les
plantes résistantes au glyphosate et
alors que l'on croyait que la substance
était désintégrer en quelques semaines
les conclusions de la chercheuse lisa
wood ont étonné la communauté
scientifique
on a des données solides qui démontre
qu'il y à du glyphosate présent dans les
plantes pendant au moins un an et on
regarde présentement quelle est la durée
de persistance maximale le temps de
dégradation du glyphosate est très
variable selon les conditions
la population ne savait pas et plusieurs
ne le savent toujours il ya des
molécules de glyphosate dans ses plans
et on ne sait pas jusqu'à quand il y en
aura la population doit réaliser que le
glyphosate persiste plus longtemps que
ce qui avait été dit à l'origine
[Musique]
le glyphosate persiste donc dans
l'environnement et fragilise la forêt
[Musique]
devant les nombreuses critiques le
ministre des forêts de la colombie
britannique a annoncé une réduction de
l'utilisation du glyphosate en
foresterie
[Musique]
et
la toxicité la mort immédiate et plantes
ces aspects ont été étudiés abondamment
mais les petites nuances celles qui
peuvent avoir des répercussions
importantes avec l'utilisation abondante
du glyphosate réunion ce que l'on ne
voit pas du premier coup d'oeil
elle nécessite plus de temps pour que
l'on comprenne réellement ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses que
la foresterie ne considère pas nous
regardons la forêt comme une ferme dans
laquelle on cultive des carottes et si
c'est pas une carotte qui pousse on s'en
débarrasse
une forêt je crois que c'est plus
compliqué que ça
[Musique]
il est temps de repenser et transformer
notre gestion de la forêt il faut penser
à augmenter la diversité pour accroître
la résilience
il faut que notre territoire soit géré
pour être mieux préparée face aux
incendies et aux ravageurs avec les
changements climatiques
ce sont ces perturbations qui vont
déterminer l'avenir de notre forêt
[Musique]
après la pause l'alternative au
glyphosate sur quatre pattes
je
[Musique]
sur les terres ancestrales de la
première nation s'auto près de chet wind
le glyphosate n'est plus le bienvenu
il a été remplacé par 400 moutons de ce
père chaumonot micro c'est le meilleur
outil qui n'est pas chimiques pour
contrôler la végétation
c'est comme une tondeuse ils ne mangent
pas de conifères mais qu'ils mangent
tout le reste
[Musique]
quand ils ont fini toute la végétation
est devenu des fertilisants et la
plantation à l'épaule contrairement aux
herbicides les moutons mangent les
plantes sans les tuer
elles reposeront l'année suivante ce qui
donne le temps aux conifères de
s'implanter
les agneaux eux seront abattus à
l'automne pour nourrir les membres de la
communauté
le troupeau de la première nation soto
est l'un des seuls à travailler pour
l'industrie forestière dans la province
ils viennent vingtaine d'années il y
avait des milliers de moutons dans la
forêt de la colombie britannique
c'était avant que le glyphosate ne
devienne l'option la moins coûteuse
enfin jeu complet audi majeur les
forestières calcule le coût à l'hectare
c'est évident qu'elle herbicides c'est
moins cher chip ou tous les moutons sont
moins sac le débroussaillage mécanique
par exemple mais tant qu'il y aura du
glyphosate
les entreprises vont l'utiliser c'est
pour ça qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
moutons en forêt gelé drina choix pour
les forestiers
oui ça crée beaucoup plus de travail
parce que évidemment quand il a quand
ils répondent ces produits ça prend
quelques heures avec un hélicoptère ou
en avion
hop c'est fait un papier à remplir c'est
fini avec nous ça prend tout l'été au
faire la même chose
la première nation soto a choisi de se
détourner du glyphosate notamment parce
qu'elle constate une baisse des
populations d'orignaux dans les
territoires traités à l'aide
d'herbicides
pour le biologiste de la communauté la
diminution des plans disponibles pour
l'alimentation des cervidés explique en
partie leur déclin on a constaté une
baisse dramatique de la population de
réunion quand ils utilisent le
glyphosate
il élimine les poses de plantes qui
reviennent habituellement sur une coupe
forestière et qui constitue normalement
l'alimentation des servites et ça
diminue énormément la biodiversité
ces coupes sont massives et maintenant
les animaux sont obligés de vivre dans
de petites zones de forêts matures
ils s'inquiètent aussi pour la
persistance du glyphosate dans les
plantes et des risques potentiels pour
la santé des membres de la communauté
l'impact négatif du glyphosate va bien
au delà des opinions des membres de la
communauté que des petits fruits sur les
coupes forestières avec la persistance
de l'herbicide dans les plantes
il est présent dans ces petits fruits il
faut maintenant s'inquiéter que notre
alimentation
soit potentiellement cancérogènes à mon
avis il s'agit dans une violation de nos
droits fondamentaux
[Musique]
la nature à créer une tondeuse monté sur
pattes qui laisse les petits arbres en
passant on pourrait pas rêver mieux
faux ce qu'on a à faire ici c'est gère
la nature ça lui a pris quelques
millions d'années a à construire cette
petite machine en beauté un côté l'herbe
et je pense pas qu'on puisse faire mieux
que ça ici
[Musique]
on